Prof: Okay,
let's get started.
The stuff we're doing these few
days are really the focus of the
first half of the semester.
So pay attention and think
about it.
Okay, so the topics today are
Overlap and Energy-Match,
as determinants of how strong
bonds are.
So we'll start with overlap.
We saw last time that overlap
is what creates the difference
density,
what focuses some small amount
of the electron density between
the atoms and serves to hold
them together.
The overlap integral is the
total amount of that product of
A and B.
Remember, you square
(A+B) and you get A^2
+ B^2 + 2AB.
That 2AB term is the
overlap.
It's called overlap because it
has values when both functions
have appreciable magnitude,
at the same point in space;
they overlap.
And summing that over all
space, or integrating it,
gives what's called the overlap
integral.
It'll depend on the distance.
Obviously if they're very far
apart,
they don't give simultaneous
values to the same point in
space,
because it's far from either
one or the other,
or from both.
So it depends on distance.
It also depends on
hybridization,
and that's what we're going to
talk about first.
Okay, first let's just look for
scale.
Here are the 2s orbitals
of carbon atom,
and you can work out,
with your formulas,
that the diameter of the
spherical node is 0.7 angstroms.
Right?
That means we have a distance
scale here.
Now, the distance between two
carbons is roughly 1.4,1.5,
when they're forming a bond
from one another -- between one
another.
Okay.
So that means we can use that
0.7 angstrom scale to see how
far we have to slide these
together, in order to get them
to bonded distance.
If we superimposed the X's --
remember those diameters are
each 0.7 --
so if we slide them together
until we superimpose the X's,
then they're 1.4 angstroms
apart.
So that's about the distance
that these two orbitals are,
in the proper scale,
when they're in a carbon-carbon
bond.
Now, how big is the overlap
integral, the sum of the product
of A times B,
over all space?
Now I want you to guess,
guess how big that integral is.
And we have a hint.
What would the overlap integral
be if we moved them until they
superimposed on one another
exactly?
That's the maximum we could
get, if the distance were zero.
So if pulled them all together,
then A and B would be measured
from the same center.
So it would be the same thing
as A^2.
Okay?
So what would the integral of
A^2^( )be, over all space?
Student:  One.
Prof: One;
that's normalization.
Okay, so the maximum value you
can get when they're right on
top of one another -- negatives
multiply negatives to get
positive;
positive areas,
multiply positive areas to get
positive.
Everything is optimum,
is going to be one.
Now I want somebody to give me
an idea, a guess,
of how big it's going to be
here, or at least some
considerations that would go
into that.
The maximum value you can get
is one.
How big do you think it would
be here?
What's something that would
hurt it;
that is, make it less than one?
Russell?
Student:  When there's
very little overlap on the
opposite sides.
Prof: Yeah,
out beyond the red areas,
there's very little overlap
altogether.
So you lose whatever overlap
you'd get from there,
in doing the normalization.
Now, in the middle,
right in the middle,
you have blue on top of blue.
That's good.
But notice there's also a node
that's going to interfere with
some of the wave functions'
overlapping,
and there's going to be a
little bit of blue on top of
red.
Everybody got that?
So I just want people to guess.
Okay, I know what I'll do.
We'll do a poll.
This is a democracy after all;
we're about to get into
November.
So I'm going to start with 0.1,
as what you think it would be.
Right?
The maximum,
if you put them right on top of
one another, is one.
So I'm going to start with 0.1,
and move up and see hands.
Okay, how many people think
it's 0.1?
0.2?
0.3?
0.4?
0.5?
0.6?
7,8, 9, one?
Obviously not one.
Now, I think,
my sense of this is it peaked
between 0.3 and 0.4,
but there were some votes for
0.2, and I would've voted for
0.2,
because it looks like you've
lost an awful lot here.
But in fact I personally am
surprised that it's pretty big.
It's 0.41.
It's almost half as big as it
would be if they were right on
top of one another,
despite the fact that you're
losing great parts of it,
that they don't overlap at all,
and there's negative overlap
where red's on top of blue.
Still the fact is it's 0.41;
so pretty big.
Now that's going to depend on
distance obviously.
Right?
So here's how it depends on
distance.
There's that point;
at 1.4 angstroms it's 0.41.
And I've put on here for
reference the distance of a
carbon-carbon single bond,
the distance of a carbon-carbon
double bond,
and a carbon-carbon triple bond.
And zero, notice,
would be way down,
out in the hallway someplace.
Right?
We're only looking at the
region that's carbon-carbon
bonds -- or maybe just about to
the far wall.
Okay?
Here's half an angstrom;
we got to go two more halves.
Right?
Okay, so here's how -- how do
you think -- what should the
line look like?
Should it be sine wave?
Should it be increasing as we
go to the left?
Should it be decreasing as we
What do you think?
Some guess.
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Should probably
decrease.
Because we know it's going to
approach one.
Right?
And there it is.
Yes, it decreases -- pardon me,
it increases as you go to the
left, and ultimately it'll go up
to one, when you get out to the
hallway.
Okay?
So that's s with
s.
Now let's look at some other
orbitals that might overlap,
and see how big their overlap
integrals would be.
Okay, suppose you have s
on one, overlapping with
p on the other.
Now that p is called,
for this purpose,
π.
p is the Greek version of
p;
in fact, in Greek you pronounce
it 'pee,' not 'pie'.
Right?
So that's the Greek letter
p.
Am I right about that?
Student:  It depends on
classical or modern Greek.
Prof: Okay,
which way is it?
Student:  It'd be 'pee'
in modern Greek;
it'd be 'pie' in classical.
Prof: Uh-huh, okay, good.
So anyhow, ‘pie'.
>
Prof: Now,
so that symbol is used to talk
about molecular orbitals,
or parts of molecular orbitals;
where p is used to talk
about atomic orbitals.
They correspond to one another.
Now what is it that
characterizes a p atomic
orbital?
Has a nodal plane.
And in the same way a
π orbital has a nodal
plane that contains the nuclei
that are in question.
Right?
So you see, if those two came
together there'd be a nodal
plane in the orbital on the
right that contains the two
nuclei.
Okay?
So that's called a π
orbital.
Okay?
Now, but notice the
contributions to the overlap.
Below that plane,
you're going to have blue
overlapping with blue.
So that's going to be a
positive contribution.
But above, you're going to have
blue overlapping with red;
that's going to be a negative
contribution,
and it's symmetrical.
So what will the total be?
What will the total overlap
integral be;
the sum of all the overlaps?
Student:  One.
Prof: One?
Prof: It'll be zero,
because for every contribution
on the bottom that's positive,
there'll be one on the top
that's the same value and is
negative.
So it's going to be zero.
So the one on the left is
called σ.
Now σ is the Greek
equivalence of 's.'
Right?
So it means,
for a molecular orbital,
what s meant for an
atomic orbital;
there are no nodes that contain
the nucleus.
Okay?
Okay, so if you have
σ overlapping with
a π,
there's going to be this
symmetry that causes a
cancellation.
So you can never get any
overlap, by overlapping a
σ orbital with a
π orbital.
Does that make sense to
everyone?
It does make sense,
doesn't make sense?
If you have one that doesn't
have a horizontal node,
that's the same top and bottom,
and one that does have a node
that's plus on the top,
minus on the bottom,
then you're going to get this
cancellation everywhere,
and zero.
And that's called
‘orthogonal'.
Okay, so you won't get any net
interaction there.
Okay, but if you turn the
p orbital so that it is
also σ --
notice it has a plane,
a nodal plane,
that contains that nucleus,
but it doesn't contain the
other nucleus you're interested
in.
So to call σ and
π, we need a plane
that contains both
nuclei.
That'll create this symmetry
that cancels things out.
Okay, so this one will give
overlap.
Now what would you expect for
the trend of this one,
as you go from great distance
to small distance?
If they're very,
very far apart,
how big will the overlap
integral be;
like ten meters apart?
Student:  Zero.
Prof: Zero. Okay?
Now, as you bring it together,
as they start coming together,
will you get positive or
negative overlap?
Students:  Positive.
Prof: Positive;
right, the blue will overlap
with the blue.
And you keep coming,
it'll get bigger and bigger.
And then what will happen?
Prof: Then the red is
going to start coming in and --
well the blue is going to
start, the blue on the right,
from the p orbital,
will start --
and going to overlap that red
part on the left.
And then, as it slides on over,
till they get exactly on top of
one another -- when they get
exactly on top of one another,
what will it be?
Students:  Zero.
Prof: Zero,
because it'll be canceling
right to left.
Okay, so here's a plot of that,
for s-p
σ_ overlap.
Right?
It's almost the same as
s with s.
In fact, it's a little bigger
at great distance,
a little smaller at small
distance;
except, at very small distance
what will happen?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: When you approach
zero?
It'll go to zero.
Whereas the other one went to
one.
Right?
The s with s went
to one.
So, but in the region we're
interested in,
the carbon-carbon bond
distances, it's about the same.
Okay, now how about
p_σ with
p_σ?
Well we won't go through an
elaborate guessing game.
If they're very far apart it'll
be zero.
How about if they were on top
of one another?
It's obviously going to grow as
blue gets on top of blue,
and then as they get really
close, the blue up from the
right will be on top of the red,
and the red on top of the blue.
Right?
So what will it approach?
Zack, what do you say?
Student:  Zero.
Prof: Approach zero?
What will it be when they're
right on top of one another?
So red on blue here;
blue on red here.
Will the overlap be zero?
Student:  Negative one.
Prof: Pardon me?
Prof: It'll be minus
one,
because it would be like the
orbital on top of itself --
that would be one -- except
you've changed the sign,
of one of them. Right?
So every contribution will be
negative.
So that one starts there,
and it's heading toward minus
one.
So it's going down.
Okay?
So that's p_σ with
p_σ.
Can you think of any other way
we should talk about it?
We've talked about s
with s.
We saw that s with
p_π_ was
orthogonal;
s with
p_σ_
we've got there;
p_σ with
p_σ.
Any others we need to think
about?
Student:
p_σ with
p_π?
Prof: How about
p_σ_ with
p_π?
Can anybody guess that one?
P_σ_ is
the same sign,
top and bottom;
p_π_ is
opposite signs,
top and bottom.
Student:  So it's zero.
Prof: That's going to be
zero.
There'll be orthogonal.
So have we done it now,
or is there anything else to
think about?
Student:  π,
π.
Prof: We could do
p_π with
p_π.
Okay, so there's p_π
with p_π.
Okay?
Now at great distance they'll
be nothing.
We'll bring them together,
they'll begin to overlap.
What will it approach as we go
to zero?
Student:  Zero.
Prof: Zero?
If they're on top of one
another, the product will be
zero?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: It'll be one,
right?
It'll be the orbital with
itself, normalized.
So that'll be one. Right?
But now which do you think is
going to be bigger,
p_σ_
with
p_σ,_ or
p_π with
p_π?
Any guesses?
Well, I'll give you the answer.
Right?
p_π with
p_π is approaching
one.
At big distance,
it's smaller than
σ.
Right?
But at small distance,
it must get much bigger,
and in this region it's
crossing;
so it's bigger.
Okay, so there are the kinds of
overlaps of simple 2p
orbitals.
Now, there's a curiosity here.
Over most of this range,
more than half of the range,
2s overlaps with
2p_σ_
better than either
2s with 2s or
2p_σ_
with 2p_σ.
That just seems curious to me.
You'd think that one of them
would have a shape that gives
better overlap.
Right?
So two of those together would
do the best job.
But it's not that way.
It's that an s with a
p is the best,
over most of this range.
I just think that's curious,
and it has an important
implication, which you'll see
right now.
What if we use hybrid orbitals,
that are partly s and
partly p?
Now, since this one is partly
s, it's s plus a
certain amount of p.
This one's s with a
The overlap will be s
here with s here;
s here with p
here;
and p here with p
here.
Right?
There'll be four contributions:
s with s;
p with p;
s with p;
p with s.
Right?
So if we took sp^3,
for example -- and we can make,
remember, four such orbitals --
then you get that.
It's better than any of the
pure hybrids.
Right?
And the reason is that it has
s with s,
and p with p;
and also s with
p, that comes in as a
bonus, twice.
Okay, now how about if we use,
instead of sp^3,
how about if we use
sp^2?
Remember what happens as we
approach sp?
The orbitals extend more.
So what do you expect?
Student:  More overlap.
Prof: More overlap.
So there's sp^2 with
sp^2, a little better.
How about sp with
sp?
Better still.
Could we get any better?
How about s^2p with
s^2p, or
sp^½ with
sp^½?
Right?
It's a little better at short
distance, and a little not so
good at long distance.
So it optimizes around
sp hybridization.
That gives the best overlap.
Why do we think now you want
good overlap?
Why would it be good to have
Student:  Keep the bonds
strong.
Prof: Because that's
what's building up the
difference density,
as we saw last time.
Right?
That's putting the glue in the
orbital.
Okay, so there's an interesting
observation here,
that hybrids overlap about
twice as well as pure orbitals.
Right?
All the hybrids are roughly
twice as good as the pure ones.
Okay?
And they're not very,
very different from one
another.
But sp is about the
best, over much of this range.
The trouble with sp is
you can only make two of them,
because each involves 50% of
s, and you only have one
s to go in it;
you have one s and three
p's.
So if you want to make just one
orbital, fine,
use sp,
because you'll get good -- only
one bond from the carbon;
fine use sp and get the
best overlap.
Or maybe even s^2p,
depending on the distance.
Right?
But if you want to make more
bonds, more than two bonds,
then you're going to have to
cut back on the s in each
bond.
Because you only have 100% to
use, you can't use more than 50%
in more than two bonds you're
making.
Okay.
And what you see here is that
sp^3^( )isn't much worse
than sp^2.
So why not make four -- right?
-- because you can.
Okay, anyhow,
that's the hybridization of
carbon.
So, and the reason they do
this, as I already said,
is because they allow nearly
full measure of s with
p overlap,
plus s with s,
and p with p,
when you have mixtures.
So that all depends on the fact
that s-p_σ
is so good in its overlap.
Now, so sp gives the
best overlap,
but only allows two orbitals,
with 50% in each;
sp^3 gives four,
and nearly as much overlap.
Okay?
Now we're going to look at the
influence of overlap on
molecular orbital energy.
But we're going to use Erwin
Meets Goldilocks,
just for familiarity.
So we're working here in just
one-dimension,
to get the idea of it.
And we'll also then think in
more general terms.
And we've already done this,
so it's partly review.
So we'll assume that there's
perfect energy match;
that is, the two atoms we're
talking about.
Of course, atoms would be
Coulombic potentials,
not harmonic oscillator,
Hooke's Law potentials.
Right?
But the idea of a
double-minimum is the same.
So we'll suppose that the atoms
are equivalent.
So the bottom of the well is
the same on both sides.
And guess an energy.
And lo and behold we were right;
we got the solution,
and you've seen that one.
Okay?
But you can also get that one,
one with one node.
Right?
And on the far left you can see
that they have the same
curvature-over-amplitude.
So they have essentially the
same energy.
If the green energy is right,
the red energy is the same
deal.
Right?
They're ‘degenerate'
orbitals, because they're far
apart.
Okay?
No significant energy
difference.
Now, suppose we increase the
overlap.
What will happen if we shorten
the distance?
You did this on a problem set
with Erwin.
Right?
So you bring them closer
together, and you have the one
with no nodes,
and the one with one node.
And now there's a little --
right halfway between there's
more electron density in one
than there is in the other.
Right?
The antibonding one has zero
and the bonding one has some
buildup of electron density in
between.
But the energy hasn't changed
visibly on this scale that we're
using.
It looks just the same.
Okay?
Now we increase it more and now
there's a big difference in the
middle.
Right?
And now the energies are
beginning to change.
The unfavorable orbital is
going up and the favorable
bonding orbital is going down in
energy.
And if we get it still closer
together, we can see that
there's now a big difference
between them.
Okay?
So that increasing overlap
creates the splitting that we
talk about.
This is just review,
as you know,
but it's worth -- it's so
important that it's good to
mention it again.
Now that overlap holds the
atoms together.
And this again is a picture we
saw before, except we're going
to do it with writing-in the
equations.
Remember, a good guess of the
form of the molecular orbital is
1/√2 (A+B),
or 1/√2 (A-B).
And that will give two new
orbitals, one better and one
worse.
And, in fact,
if you think about
normalization,
it should be a little less than
1/√2,
in the one that's going to have
+2AB in it,
when you square it,
and a little less than
1/√2 when it's
going to have a minus sign for
the 2AB term.
Okay?
Now, because of that ‘a
little bit greater' and ‘a
little bit less',
the energies aren't quite,
as we saw them before,
equally split, up and down.
The one that goes down doesn't
go down quite as much,
because this is less than,
and the one that goes up,
goes up a little more because
it's greater than.
The mathematical requirement
for that isn't immediately
obvious to you,
but it's true.
Okay, so there are the new
orbitals you get when you bring
the atoms together.
Okay?
And if you had more overlap,
there'd be a bigger difference.
So that's why overlap is
important.
The more overlap,
the more splitting.
We just saw that in
one-dimension with Erwin
Meets Goldilocks.
Now, how many electrons do we
have to put in these orbitals?
That's going to make a big
difference.
So suppose we have just one
electron for these two orbitals.
When we bring the two wells
together, when we bring the two
atoms together,
that electron will go down in
energy, to the new molecular
orbital.
So that's going to be good.
And if we tried to pull them
apart,
the electron would have to go
back up in energy,
and that would require energy,
and that would oppose the
breaking.
So that's the bond strength.
Right?
You have to put an electron up
that much.
Now suppose there were two
electrons.
Now a second one goes down the
same way.
So it's even stronger.
It won't, in truth,
be quite twice as strong.
Do you see why?
Yes?
Student:  Electron
repulsion.
Prof: Because the
electrons will repel one
another.
We haven't taken that into
account when we think about the
energies here.
But it'll be certainly
stronger, considerably stronger.
Okay.
Now suppose we had three
electrons.
What's going to happen?
Prof: One of them is
going to have to go up instead
of down.
And, in fact,
it will go up further than
either of the others went down,
even neglecting electron
repulsion -- right?
-- because of that
‘greater than/less than'
thing that shifted the pair up a
little bit.
Okay?
So that's going to be even
weaker than having one electron
to hold them together,
when you have three.
How about if you have four?
Student:  No more bonds.
Prof: Wilson?
Student:  They'll be
antibonding, so --
Prof: Yeah,
you're now definitely losing,
because the two that go up,
go up more than the two that go
down, go down.
So that's bad.
So we can summarize that here,
the effect on the bond.
If you have one electron,
it's bonding;
two electrons is strongly
bonding;
three electrons is weakly
bonding, probably;
and four electrons will
definitely be antibonding.
So that's why helium bounces
off helium,
until it gets fifty-two
angstroms apart,
and then there's this very,
very, very weak bond,
that we talked about,
due to the correlation of the
electrons.
Right?
But as soon as you get overlap
with helium, it's repulsive,
when you start to split these
levels.
Okay, now let's look at the
other end.
Why doesn't increasing overlap,
as you bring things closer
together, why doesn't that make
these plum-puddings collapse?
The electrons are getting more
and more stable as you increase
the overlap by bringing things
closer together.
So why doesn't it just collapse?
In fact, the electron -- if a
hydrogen molecule collapsed to
helium --
it would be a funny helium
because it would have no
neutrons --
but if it collapsed,
the electrons,
indeed, would become 55% more
stable.
The electrons in helium are
lower in energy than the
electrons in H_2.
Right?
So that would tend to pull them
together, all the way,
to distance zero.
Why don't they?
Elizabeth?
Student:  The protons
repel.
Prof: Because the
protons will repel one another.
That depends on 1/r.
Right?
And that increases much more
dramatically.
In fact, the amount by which
the electrons become more stable
is 650 kcal/mole,
or would become more stable.
Right?
But the nuclear repulsion
increases by that much by the
time they get to 0.3 angstroms,
let alone the last little bit,
when 1/r gets enormous.
Okay?
So it's not worth it;
unless you have glue to hold
the neutrons together.
Right?
So on the sun you can take
deuterium and fuse it into --
to make a helium -- you have
neutrons there to hold the
protons together --
and then you get 200 million
kcal/mole;
which is, of course,
nuclear energy,
not electronic energy.
It is possible,
but not under the chemical
circumstances that we're talking
about.
Okay, so here's the Morse
potential.
Yes, Lucas?
Student:  Have we been
taking proton-proton repulsion
into account before,
with all our energies?
Prof: No,
or only sort of subliminally.
Right?
Because if you take -- at first
glance there's going to be
nuclear-nuclear repulsion,
and electron-electron
repulsion, between the atoms;
nuclear-electron attraction;
nuclear-electron attraction.
So to first approximation,
those will all cancel out.
Right?
But then you get -- on top of
that you have a little change
from the fact that the
nuclear-nuclear goes as
1/r and gets quite big,
when they get really close,
and that the electrons are
coming down because of overlap.
And we've been focusing on this
overlap thing that causes the
bonding, but obviously things
aren't going to collapse because
of the nuclear part.
But we haven't been talking
about it explicitly;
you're right.
Okay, so anyhow this is the
form of the bonding potential,
the Morse potential,
which was just cobbled together
artificially to make it
convenient to calculate things
and to have reasonable
properties for a bond.
But now we understand why it
should look like that.
This first part,
the attractive part,
is because the electron pair
becomes more stable with
increasing overlap,
as the atoms come together.
And then the nuclear repulsion
becomes dominant,
when it becomes too close.
Right?
So all this is Coulomb's Law.
There's nothing special.
There's not
‘correlation
energy', which is some
completely new physical
phenomenon.
Right?
It's all Coulombic.
Correlation energy is just,
remember, an excuse for the
error you're making,
or a way to hide it.
Okay, so it all comes from
Coulomb's Law for potential
energy.
But the funny thing was the
kinetic energy of the electrons,
according to Schrödinger.
Right?
Because as you make things --
as you concentrate things,
you change the curvature as
well.
So you have to take that into
account.
But this curve provides the
potential for studying molecular
vibration;
that is, once you know the form
of this curve,
then you can use quantum
mechanics for the motion of the
atoms --
not of the electrons but of the
and figure out how atoms
vibrate;
which we've already done,
when we were doing Erwin
Meets Goldilocks.
Okay, but here,
finally we understand the
atom-atom force law.
Right?
That's what we've been doing
the whole time,
for four weeks or five weeks or
whatever it's been,
is trying to understand where
-- what the force law is.
Wouldn't Newton be happy?
Remember, he said,
"There are therefore
agents in Nature able to make
particles of bodies stick
together by very strong
attractions,
and it's the business of
Experimental Philosophy to find
them out."
And now we've found it out.
Now, can we use this
understanding then to gain
greater purchase on chemistry?
So we've looked at overlap.
But there's one other thing we
have to look at,
in order to apply it,
and that's what we call
energy-match.
I don't think anybody else
talks about energy-match,
but we do.
Okay, so here's what we talked
about already.
Right?
And we have this splitting,
which is about proportional to
overlap.
It's not numerically strictly
proportional to overlap,
but it certainly is close to
proportional to overlap.
Okay, now what would happen if
the two atoms you started with
were not the same,
if one was a better place for
electrons to be than the other;
like there for example?
So why would you -- remember
what happened is you mix these.
You get A+B and A-B.
But why would you put
any A together
with B, if B is already much
better than A?
If they're equal,
you don't care where it is,
then fine, use a 50/50 mixture.
But if one's better than the
other, why use any of the
inferior one?
Why not just use the one that's
good?
So we already actually saw this
in the case of the 1s
atomic orbitals,
which did remain pure and
unmixed, when we made the
molecular orbitals of that funny
molecule last time,
the fluoroethanol.
Remember, it looked like that.
One of them was just an
s orbital on F;
another one was an s
orbital on O;
s orbital on one carbon,
s orbital on the other
carbon.
The didn't mix. Right?
So the compact 1s core
orbitals did remain pure and
unmixed, but the valence level
atomic orbitals were heavily
mixed.
For example,
the next one was biggest on
fluorine, but also substantial
on oxygen, and carbon even got
into the act a little bit.
Right?
Now why is it that the core
orbitals didn't mix and the
valence orbitals did mix?
What's different?
The core orbitals are very
small, very compact.
These orbitals are bigger.
So what happens?
They overlap. Right?
So it's overlap that causes
things to mix.
If there's no overlap they
don't mix.
If they overlap they mix.
So why use any of an inferior
orbital?
Well suppose the energy of A is
much higher, less favorable,
than that of B. Right?
So now we make a sum,
a weighted sum,
a parts of A,
b parts of B,
and we square it.
So we get a^2^( )parts
of the A density,
b^2^( )parts of the B
density, and also this overlap
term, 2ab.
Now, can you profit from
shifting electron density toward
the inter-nuclear AB region,
without paying too much of the
high energy cost of A?
That is, A^2^( )is higher
energy than B^2.
Right?
The electron density around A
is higher energy than the
electron density about B.
And if you mix A with B,
you're going to get a certain
amount of that bad,
or less good,
distribution,
A^2.
But at the same time you're
going to get some of AB,
which puts stuff in the middle,
at the expense of outside.
That's good. Right?
At a certain distance from the
nuclei, you'd rather be between
the two nuclei than out beyond
one of them.
So as you increase a,
you increase -- oops sorry
>
-- you increase this bad part,
but you also increase that good
part.
Can it be worthwhile to make
a non-0?
Which one is going to help?
But notice this.
If you put only a small amount
of A in, then the amount of
A^2^( )probability density,
this bit here,
is a^2 parts of that;
really, really tiny,
if a is tiny.
But the amount of ab you
put in is a times
b, not a^2.
Right?
So it's much bigger.
So you get this good stuff,
without getting very much of
this bad stuff.
Right?
For example,
suppose you used,
a was 0.03 and b
was 0.98.
So you square them,
to find out how much --
<<technical
adjustment>>
-- you square them,
and you find out that the
amount of a^2 you get is
only 0.001.
The amount of b^2 is
0.96.
And the amount of 2ab is
0.06.
So you're getting sixty times
as much of ab as you get
of a^2.
So that's why it can be useful
to put a little bit in.
And if you're pedantic,
you can look at the footnote
there.
So let's look at Erwin Meets
Goldilocks in the case where
the two wells are not matched,
where the energies are a little
bit different;
because that's what we're
talking about.
So here are non-degenerate
atomic orbitals.
So the one on the left is a
little bit lower than the one on
the right, but only a teeny bit.
Okay?
Now we're going to look at the
wave functions here.
So there's the lowest energy
wave function.
Right?
And notice it's the sum,
it's a weighted sum,
with no nodes.
But there's almost no mixing at
all, just a really,
really, really tiny amount of A
in it.
So essentially it's just the
solution you'd get in the left
well.
Right?
There'd be one with one node as
well.
What will it look like,
can you guess?
This is the one with zero nodes.
What's the wave function with
one node look like?
Any guesses?
Yes, Josh?
Student:  It'll just
have a node in the middle of
that first potential and then be
straight on the second one.
Prof: And be what?
Student:  And be sort of
straight on the second one.
Prof: Right.
So the first one,
the lowest one,
is the one on the left.
The second one,
the next highest energy
orbital, is the one on the
right, with just a little bit of
the one on the left in it;
negligible amount of mixing.
Right?
And their energies,
you might think their energies
would be the same,
because they're not mixing.
But the green one is in this
well, and the red one is in that
well, and that well's higher.
Okay?
So it's got to be higher in
energy.
That spitting is due only to
the original offset between the
wells.
There's no shift of it. Right?
It's just you have A or you
have B, and you have what you
would expect for them.
Now suppose we increase the
overlap between these.
What do you think is going to
happen?
You should get a little more
mixing because AB is going to
count for more,
if you have overlap.
Okay, so here they are close
together.
You still don't have very much
mixing, just a little bit,
and you haven't seen any
appreciable change in the
energies.
You still have that same
splitting that's due to the
original offset.
Okay?
Now we'll bring them still
closer together.
And now it's getting worthwhile
to put it in the wrong well,
because the AB term is so
important.
Right?
So the antibonding energy is
rising,
the bonding energy is falling
-- that's why they're
antibonding and bonding --
and if we bring them still
closer together,
we get that. Right?
Which, if you looked at it
casually, they look like a
single well.
But notice that they're still
quite unsymmetrical,
they're still biased.
The one without any nodes is
still mostly in the left well,
and the one with a node is
mostly in the right well.
But they're heavily mixed.
Right?
So what's happening is this
increasing overlap,
as you bring them together,
is fighting the effect of the
difference in the two wells.
So when we had the core
electrons in fluoroethanol,
if we had tiny orbitals that
didn't overlap,
then they stayed pure.
Right?
But once we went to the valence
level orbitals,
that were much bigger,
so that they overlapped,
then they started mixing,
like this.
Okay, now what if one partner
is lower in energy than A?
That's the case we're dealing
with.
But what will these ultimate
energies be,
when you have this competition
between overlap,
which is trying to mix them,
and energy mismatch,
which is trying to keep them
separate from one another?
So here's what you get.
You get again splitting,
but not as much shift as you
got before.
The lower level will look
mostly like C,
because C is better than A.
The antibonding will look
mostly like A,
with just a little bit of C in
it.
And if they had had the same
energy, you'd get a big energy
shift because of overlap.
But now you get a smaller
energy shift,
because the mismatch is
fighting that.
Right?
You don't want to -- you lose
as you try to mix,
because of the difference
between A and C,
in this case.
Now, so that one looks mostly
like C, both in shape and in
energy.
That one looks mostly like A,
both in shape and energy.
But it's a little worse than A,
and the first one is a little
better than C.
Now how much smaller is that
bonding shift?
When they were mismatched,
they didn't shift as much with
the same overlap.
How much less?
Exactly where does it end up?
Well that's not so crucially
important to you,
but there's a neat trick you
can do to see that.
Suppose we have that much
energy mismatch.
Okay?
And the red dot is halfway
between B and C,
or between A and C,
since A and B are the same
energy.
Now, so when they were
perfectly matched,
A and B perfectly matched in
energy, that's how much
splitting you got from that
amount of overlap.
So these are the two factors
that go into it:
how much splitting you get when
they have the same energy,
and how different the original
energies are.
How can you put those together,
to find out how much shift you
actually get?
Well what we do is slide that
over,
and then bend down the blue
one, so it's perpendicular to
that,
and make a rectangle around it,
and draw the diagonal.
And that diagonal will be the
new energy difference between
the new levels.
Okay?
You say, why do I make this
construction?
It's because there's a
quadratic formula that comes in.
So the diagonal is the square
root of the squares of the two
sides, the sum of the squares of
the two sides.
Okay, so we can rotate that;
put a tack in there and rotate
it.
And that's going to be the new
energy difference.
Okay?
And it's bigger than the
original energy difference,
because the diagonal has to be
bigger than one of the sides.
But because of the
normalization,
because one of them is a little
less than --
one of them is a little smaller
and one's a little greater --
that was the less than/greater
than √2,
1/√2 thing -- it's
going to shift up a little bit,
both levels will shift up a
little bit, like that.
Right?
I'll do it again so you see it.
Both will shift up.
So there are the new levels.
That's how you do it.
Okay?
Now, so for a given overlap,
the bonding shift,
how much the electrons changed
when the atoms came together,
is reduced if the energies
aren't well matched,
if you have the same overlap.
You don't get as strong a bond,
from that point of view.
The energies didn't shift down
as much, or up as much.
But still A+C will be lower in
energy than the original one
was, A+B.
Okay?
And we had that construction,
which shows us an interesting
thing,
which is the splitting is not
very sensitive to the one of
these contributions that's
smaller.
There are two contributions:
the overlap part,
that's the black arrow -- or
pardon me,
that's the blue arrow -- and
the energy difference,
the energy mismatch,
which is the black arrow.
But if one of those is very
small, like here,
the mismatch,
which is black,
is very big,
and the overlap,
the blue one,
is very small.
But you can see that the length
of the diagonal is not going to
be very sensitive to what the
overlap is.
You could increase that blue
overlap, the width of the
rectangle, which wouldn't change
the diagonal very much.
So it's sensitive to the one
that's bigger.
Okay, don't worry too much
about that part.
I just think it's fun.
Okay, so we can generalize from
this.
Mixing two overlapping orbitals
gives one composite orbital
that's lower in energy than
either of the parents,
and one that's higher in energy
than either of the parents.
Okay?
The lower energy combination
looks -- that is,
its shape -- is most like the
lower energy parent;
and the same is true for
energy.
Right?
And the higher one looks like
the higher parent.
For a given overlap,
increasing energy mismatch
decreases the amount of mixing,
and decreases the magnitude of
the energy shifts.
Now what does this have to do
with bonding?
Okay, the AC electrons are
clearly lower in energy.
But that's not really what
we're interested in.
We're interested in the
change of energy
that comes when you break the
bond, or make the bond.
So which bond is stronger,
AB or AC?
How many think AB is stronger,
given this scheme?
How many think AC is stronger?
It's clearly got lower energy
electrons, AC.
But this is a classic example
of "compared to what?"
Okay?
How are we going to break the
bond?
Suppose what we're going to do
is break it, to put two
electrons in C,
because that's the lower energy
atom;
or in the other case,
to put two electrons in B.
Okay?
So both electrons go the same
way.
Can you see anything bad about
that?
Why might it be better to put
one electron each way?
Kevin?
Student:  Well in terms
of spin, they have to be --
Prof: Not spin.
You can put two electrons in an
orbital with opposite spin.
So spin's not a problem,
if you only have two.
If you had three it would be a
problem, but with two,
spin is not a problem.
But there's an obvious problem
with having both the electrons
go to one.
Dana?
Student:  They'll repel
each other.
Prof: They'll repel each
other.
If you could put them on
opposite ones,
so much the better.
Right?
But it would be possible to do
this, and it might plausible in
the case of AC,
where C is lower in energy than
A;
although the repulsion might
make it better to go one on C
and one on A.
Okay, but anyhow,
suppose you break it this way.
Which one would be easier to
break?
Which requires less energy,
red or blue?
Students:  Red.
Prof: Red requires less
energy.
Okay, so AB is stronger,
if you're forming A^+ B^-,
if both the electrons are going
the same way.
Right?
So mismatch aids heterolysis.
Heterolysis,
(uneven breaking) is to put
them both on the same side,
rather than one on each side
(that's called homolysis,
as you'll see in a second).
So if you put them both on one
side, then it's easier to break
if they're mismatched.
The bond is stronger if they're
well matched.
Okay?
That's because that.
But now suppose you do
homolysis and put one on each.
Now which one's easier?
Student:  The blue one.
Prof: Now the blue is
less energy than the red.
Okay?
So now the AC is going to be
stronger.
So mismatch hinders homolysis.
Right?
So you can't really say which
bond is stronger,
unless you say,
"Compared to what -- how
are you breaking it apart?"
Okay?
Is all this true?
So I've been weaving this
fairytale for you,
for the last couple of weeks,
but is it true?
Well, we can check it with
experiment.
For example, compare HH with HF.
HH has perfect matching between
the two atoms.
In HF, there's a much bigger
nuclear charge on F;
electrons in the valence
orbital are lower in energy on F
than they are on H.
Okay, so if we look at the
σ orbital,
the valence σ
orbital,
it's symmetrical in the case of
H_2 and quite unsymmetrical in
the case of HF.
It's big on F and small on H,
just as we were speaking of.
That's the σ,
big on F. Right?
But there's also an antibonding
orbital, σ,
which has a node.
So that one is the contrary;
it's big on H, small on F.
This is just what we were
talking about a few minutes ago.
And the electrons,
of course, are only in the
σ*,
not in the σ*;
there are only two electrons
and that one's empty.
And the * means that it's
antibonding.
Right?
So it has the node between the
nuclei, planar in the
symmetrical case and bent in the
case of HF;
but it's still the node.
Now, how about the experiment?
Heterolysis,
where you break,
in order to get H^+ H^-,
in one case,
or H^+ F^- in the other case.
In the case of HH,
it costs 400 kilocalories to
break the bond.
In the case of HF,
it costs only 373.
Incidentally,
this is a lot of energy,
to break this bond,
because you're putting both the
electrons the same place.
It can happen in solution,
but it's not so easy in the gas
phase, which is what we're
talking about.
Okay, so indeed we were right,
that mismatch weakens the bond;
for heterolysis,
the HF bond is weaker.
That's why you call it
hydrofluoric acid,
because it can easily break off
an H.
You don't call H_2 hydrogenic
acid or something like that.
Right?
But if you break it into two
atoms,
two H atoms or an H atom and an
F atom, then it costs only 104
for HH, but 136 for HF.
So the HF bond is stronger,
if you're breaking to atoms.
So that's the first
verification,
experimental verification,
of what I've been talking to
you about.
And we're going to go on next
time to talk about XH_3,
which will have lots of
experimental data that will show
that this stuff is sensible.